[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time and
you know what that means it's time for
another horror book review
now i have to admit that as far as
horror subgenres go
demonic possession stories aren't
usually my favorite thing um you know
usually you guys know it's i'm more of
like a haunted house girl which i guess
this kind of is too but i'm not hugely
into demon possession i'm not averse to
them but you know it's not usually my
favorite genre but
for some reason
while i was kind of scrolling through my
kindle recommendations
nick roberts
2022 novel the exorcists house
kind of popped out at me i'm not really
sure why
exactly i don't know if i just liked the
sound of the name or if it's just kind
of like because the cover is nice but
it's not like all that striking or
anything
so i was like oh what the hell uh you
know it's it was free to read with
kindle unlimited so i said i'll give it
a whirl
so nick roberts is actually a west
virginia based author uh who actually
won the debut novel of the year award
back in 2021 for his first novel which
was called anathema so the exorcist
house is actually his second book and as
far as i know he's working on his third
one now i think he teaches as well and i
will say right out of the gate that even
though the exorcist house isn't the most
original thing ever like i said you know
what is um it was still a hell of a lot
of fun i had a i had a good time with it
and i definitely recommend it if you're
into just real classic exorcism tropes
uh also has some nods to rosemary's baby
in there which i actually like really
appreciated so the novel is set in the
author's home state west virginia in the
1990s
and it starts out with kind of like a
brief prologue which takes place in the
spring i believe it's march 1993.
there's an old man named merle blatty
and he's kind of just sitting on a rock
on his land having a smoke and talking
to his faithful bloodhound book
now from the tone of his thoughts and
the stuff that he's saying to the dog
we're led to believe that he's kind of
resigned to whatever his fate is going
to be
and he's ready to go back into his
farmhouse and deal with whatever the
[ __ ] is going on in there so because the
name of the book is the exorcists house
uh you're led to assume that there's
some demonic shenanigans occurring
inside the house and that the old man
has kind of come to terms with the fact
that he's not being going to be able to
survive the upcoming battle
he even briefly considers and this
almost made me panic for a second
because you guys know how i do he even
briefly considers like killing the dog
like as a mercy killing and i was like
no please don't do that
but thankfully uh he decides oh he's
gonna let the good boy go and fend for
himself in the surrounding woods after
whatever's going to happen you know ends
up going down
so i will say just right jump thank you
thank you thank you nick roberts for not
killing the dog jesus christ i'm getting
really really bummed out by all of these
horror novels bumping off the cute pets
like i said kill all the people you want
to give a [ __ ] but leave the goddamn
animals alone so uh so yeah so it was
actually kind of nice to
read a book where the dog not only
spoiler alert survives but again spoiler
alert uh helps you know is kind of in
there helping uh to fend off the evil at
the end and we do love a hero animal uh
in stories so anyway after merle is
evidently uh dispatched by this demon
that he's fighting we jump ahead a
little more than a year to april of 1994
and then we start to follow our main
protagonists who are the hill family
so you have dad daniel and he's a
psychologist like with his own practice
and then the mom nora i think she's like
a high school teacher and she's also six
months pregnant at the beginning and the
couple also have a 16 year old daughter
named alice now daniel has gotten this
wild idea into his head for whatever
reason
that he's going to buy a farm in rural
west virginia for cheap like he just
found one that was cheap and we'll know
why in a minute uh he's gonna fix it up
and then sell it for profit so
essentially flip it is what he was going
to do
now nora is kind of less enthused about
this idea but she decides she's going to
go along with it anyway
partly because or maybe even mostly
because she actually feels really guilty
because she had sort of like a fling one
night stand type of situation with a
co-worker i think was like actually her
boss or like the principal at her school
or something like that and she never
told daniel about it so she feels really
bad so she's just kind of like okay well
i'm just gonna go along with whatever he
says because i feel really guilty so
that's why so i guess the family is
gonna live in the farmhouse like for a
little while like over the summer or
whatever um at least until all the
renovations are complete and then after
they sell it they're gonna move back to
the city and hopefully have like a bunch
more money in their bank account because
i think like the way that it was
described like i guess this farm is like
an hour away from where they used to
live and like daniel is still gonna be
working um but nora is out for the
summer because she's a teacher and then
like by the time the new school year
starts she'll be on maternity leave
anyway so they're kind of figuring he's
just gonna commute and she's just gonna
be on maternity leave so they're gonna
be like an hour away from where their
house was before now naturally it will
surprise no one that the farmhouse and
the lands surrounding it that they have
purchased belonged to merle blatty and
the reason that it was so reasonably
priced was because the house was
actually partially damaged by
a little bit of a weird fire very
vaguely unnatural fire
that occurred on the night that merle
was killed so actually only the second
floor was affected i don't know if it
burned off the whole second floor but it
was just kind of like one room on the
second floor like where the demonic [ __ ]
took place
so daniel actually like hires a crew to
come in and do a bunch of work on the
house like before they get there
so by the time the hill family arrives
uh a lot of the renovation work has been
done at least the major stuff and the
place looks fantastic there's just like
some little stuff to do like out in the
yard like you know building a fence and
crap like that but the foreman of the
construction crew uh sees something like
on their last day like he sees something
peeking out at him from the basement uh
something that looks a little like i
said a little demonic and a few days
later seemingly commits suicide in a
really really gruesome way now the hills
find out about this like a day or two
after it happens and they're like bummed
out but they're not overly concerned
because the guy actually died at a motel
in town like it's not like he killed
himself like in the house or anything
like that that they're gonna be living
in
one thing that does sort of bother them
though is that somebody has been inside
the house like in the last few days
because daniel has been up there and has
been inside the house like checking out
all the work and stuff and then like a
few days later they moved all their
stuff in and he's like hey it wasn't
like this before but when they come in
there he's like somebody's been in here
like broke in here and nailed the door
to the basement shut like putting all
the um all the nails like in the shape
of a cross so not too long after the
hill family moves in they discovered
that their house of course used to
belong to merle blatty who they find out
uh wasn't actually sanctioned by the
church like he wasn't a priest or
anything like that but he was something
of a quote-unquote backwoods exorcist
who had actually trained with some
sympathetic like clergymen like some
priests that were actually sanctioned by
the church and he would occasionally
like help out in possession cases across
the country sometimes like where the
official church didn't want to get
involved or they'd already been in there
and they thought nothing was going on
and like so he would just go and help
people like around the country and had
been doing it for several years like i
think 20 years he'd been doing yeah
because i think he started out in 1973.
so he'd been doing it for 20 years
so a lot of the information that we
learn about merle
actually comes from a kind of a younger
man i think he's 17 or 18 or something
like that his name is luke and he lives
with his dad nearby
and he used to do kind of handyman stuff
and yard work like he would mow merle's
lawn and [ __ ] like that uh you know
around the farm when merle was alive
so luke comes there and said hey you
know merle used to like pay me to do all
this work around the farm and i can do
that for you still if you want i can fix
your fence i can mow your
lawn i can do all this other kind of
stuff so the hills are like yeah great
you know that'd be awesome because like
i said you know daniel's got to work and
nora's you know real pregnant so they
need somebody to kind of like fix some
stuff up so they're very happy too and
he seems like a really nice kid and
everything and the daughter alice is
like really really smitten with him they
seem like smitten with each other and
kind of start having like a little bit
of a not i wouldn't call it a romance
necessarily but a little pre-romance i
guess it doesn't really get that far but
yeah um oh and also merle's old dog buck
who like i said he let him
loose in the woods like after he went
off to fight the demon and got killed so
he's been living in the woods this whole
time uh he actually returns and gets
adopted into the family so that's nice
like i said i was i was worried about
what was going to happen to the dog but
it's fine he survives very slowly though
as usually happens in stories like this
weird [ __ ] starts to happen
most of the stuff at first kind of
revolves around the door to the basement
kind of like coming open by itself um
various family members seemingly i don't
even know if i'd want to call it
sleepwalking but sometimes they like end
up down there uh and kind of seeing
horrible things that are specifically
tailored to them like usually like what
their guilt is or what like for example
like nora sees the guy she's left with
and stuff like that
they attribute these events to kind of
like stress streams at first because you
know they've been going through a lot
but then they also start to notice like
some other weird [ __ ] like they're also
having instances of like missing time
like some of them will um you know it's
like they go to the kitchen or they go
and do something and then like several
hours pass by but to them it only seemed
like a couple minutes and then they come
up back out and they're like where the
[ __ ] have you been and they're like what
are you talking about i just went in
there like five minutes ago they're like
dude it's been like three hours what the
[ __ ] so there's like all this missing
time type [ __ ] going on too so then
finally daniel he gets very curious
about this little secret room like it's
kind of like the amityville horror a
little bit that he discovers in the
basement that ends up containing this
real real deep well that somebody has
hung crucifixes and [ __ ] over and like
put kind of a cover over it with a cross
and all this other kind of stuff
now so he goes down there one night to
like to see what this is because he
finds like a bunch of trunks and
everything like that that presumably
like uh belonged to merle and his uh
late wife that's like a bunch of their
clothes and stuff
uh but when he's down there this one
particular night when he can't sleep he
actually is confronted with the quite
terrifying looking spirit of merle
blatty himself who
appears as like a charred corpse because
that's how he died like he burned up
like that like he's a nice ghost and
everything but he can't help like the
way he looks and he just keeps getting
burned like over and over and that's
what he looks like he looks all melted
and [ __ ] so he shows up and he basically
tells daniel um you have to read through
all of the journals that i left behind
like in this other trunk that's like in
this secret room with me and you have to
figure out how to seal this well that's
in the basement because of course it is
a gateway to hell so daniel ends up
finding the old man's journals and a
bunch of videotapes of all his previous
exorcisms like over the past however
many years i think he started
videotaping them in the 80s and daniel
starts to become like obsessed with
going through them
meanwhile the demon from the well is
kind of [ __ ] with everybody's minds
making them see like really really
horrible [ __ ] uh you know stuff that
isn't there like making them see family
members doing stuff that they're not
doing and all this other kind of stuff
apparently it seems like just trying to
so chaos and like trying to turn them
against one another things like that
so this kind of all keeps going until it
comes to a head and then that leads up
to this big kind of classic exorcism
battle royale between the family and
then this priest that they summon who
had actually known merle and like
trained him a long time ago and so
they're kind of fighting this demon
that's inhabiting this well in the
basement and the whole scene like at the
end it's very very very classic like i
said exorcism stuff there's levitations
and fire and like people with like fire
in their eyes [ __ ] up visions and
gloppy black substances driven from the
ceiling all that kind of crazy [ __ ] so
as i said this was actually like a
pretty fun read and you know kept me
interested very compelling like all the
way up to the very end i had a couple
like very minor nitpicks really um one
thing and i think i've brought this up
on a review of another book although i
can't remember what it was but every now
and then like the author would
occasionally switch points of view from
character to character like within a
single scene and i'm always like a
little bit confused when that happens
because i'm always like i know this
isn't a hard and fast rule but i was
always like more of an advocate of if
you're gonna switch the pov like of a
character like if you're inside this
character's head and then you want to go
into another character's head then i
would usually like change a little
section like start a new section just to
keep it like so it's not confused and
you're not like hopping from brain to
brain like in one scene um i just find
that kind of jarring and a little bit
confusing it didn't happen a lot in the
book but it did happen a couple times
and it sort of like stuck out to me like
i said not a huge deal but that was just
like a minor nitpick that i had um so
there's that
also i have to say at first when i was
reading like the big
end like the big you know uh battle
royale like i said at the end like the
big final confrontation between the
family and the demon i thought it was a
little bit i don't know if i want to say
abrupt but it seemed like it could have
gone on a little bit longer or it was
maybe like too easy or something like
that
but after i kept reading and then
there's like because after the big
exorcism battle there's like a coda that
kind of says what happened in the
aftermath and after i read all of that
um that kind of and i'm not gonna spoil
it but that kind of like introduced a
new complication into the story which i
actually really liked so then i kind of
retroactively was like i didn't mind the
confrontation being kind of short it's
not that short but i thought it was just
like a little bit shorter than maybe it
should have been but after i read to the
end i was just kind of like oh okay i
kind of feel i kind of felt like i knew
why he maybe did that at that point so
it didn't like bother me as much so all
in all uh i would definitely recommend
this if you're a fan of like movies like
the exorcist or rosemary's baby or
amityville horror which i mentioned
before
it's a very very classic demon
possession style narrative but
it has kind of enough unique character
to make it its own thing and make it
worthwhile and it comes across as like
real gruesome like a bunch of real gory
[ __ ] happens in it and it's very very
cinematic like the way that it's written
uh so that was definitely like points in
its favor you know it moved along at a
good pace and it introduced um i think
my favorite concept about it was the
demon being able to like show you really
realistic hallucinations so you were
never really sure if what the
protagonists were seeing was what was
really going on because they would each
see their own thing like and it was like
i said tailored specifically to them
like because the demon knew what would
bother them the most and so it would
show them that like other people would
be like what the [ __ ] are you looking at
i don't see anything so it was that kind
of thing so i really liked that there
was that kind of ambiguity about
what you were seeing and like whether it
was real or not so i thought that was
like kind of cool and i think that was
probably like my best part of the story
and honestly i kind of feel like this
would be a really good one you know now
that it's september at last so we're
coming up into fall and we're coming up
into halloween and everything like that
and this seemed to me even though it's
actually set in the spring and summer
it actually comes across to me as like
just kind of like a real good like
halloween type of story just because
it's so classic and it's so exorcisty
and uh you know so if you like that kind
of thing then you will probably really
uh like this a lot as i said if you have
kindle unlimited you can read it on
there for free or of course you can of
course get the paperback if you want to
do that so that will do it for this
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
again on the next one bye